[Music]
on this Saturday night a Manitoba
community in mourning paying tribute to
lives lost as we begin to learn about
those killed in Thursday's Highway crash
and advice from the mayor of Humboldt
Lessons Learned From the tragic bus
crashed there massacre at a Ugandan
School how they've been cool
dozens killed others kidnapped The
Manhunt now underway
and permanent flight cancellation
WestJet shuts down sun wing
full National with Donna freezing
at this intersection along the
trans-canada highway in Manitoba people
are stopping to lay flowers paying
tribute to the 15 people who died here
when the bus they were in and a
transport truck collided
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are in Dolphin Manitoba tonight where
most of the dead and injured from that
crash are from it's a small City about 8
500 people live here and almost everyone
has a connection to those who were
killed and injured Global spoke with one
man who knows the pain they're going
through in 2016 his son-in-law died in a
different crash at that same
intersection and he was driving nearby
when this latest one happened Thursday
there was an ambulance behind me there
was an ambulance in front of me it was a
cop car passed me full speed I knew
there was something going on up West I
knew it would have been that
intersection of sure enough as soon as
we about a mile away two miles away from
that intersection we can see the black
smoke I told her I said hey I said
sure enough I just brought back
everything because we sat there that
night we sat there the next day a week
for a week we sat there trying to figure
out why why why
stop asking why
some of the survivors of the latest bus
crash are still in the hospital in
Brandon and in Winnipeg and because of
the way the crash happened most of them
have serious injuries Mike droulet has
an update on that
outside Winnipeg's Health Sciences
Center family and friends of the
surviving victims of the tragic
trans-canada Highway crash speak in hush
tones if they're able to speak at all
through their grief with so much
uncertainty around prognoses they don't
know what to say
the horrors of Thursday's crash continue
to cast a long Shadow over Manitoba most
of the survivors all seniors were
ejected from the bus onto the highway
after it was hit by the semi truck these
are quite extensive injuries like I said
six of them are in critical care
receiving
life-saving support
many Orthopedic injuries as you can
imagine and some others as well but
predominance of Orthopedic injuries
although police have said the semi had
the right of way determining all the
contributing factors won't be easy
investigators have said they need to
know more about the condition of the
vehicles and how fast they were going
the question that we're more interested
in is going to be did the the bus driver
attempt to cross both directions to
travel at once or did they come to a
stop and yield in between the lanes
before proceeding Lloyd Claussen who has
driven trucks for over 40 years knows
the Carberry intersection well oh a
number of so many times Clawson says as
soon as the bus entered the path of the
semi there was no avoiding a crash if
this truck would have been a car car the
the car will come to a quick stop but
you can't come to a quick stop with an
18-wheeler not with a super B I drive a
super B and you're looking at 130 40 000
pounds at 100 in 10 kilometers an hour
how can you stop sadly the answer to
that question played out for all to see
even the most hardened to accidents like
tow truck operator Robin Watton are
having a hard time processing this one
I've seen stuff that kind of turned my
stomach and just like the families of
the victims in hospital he can't say any
more than that microlight Global News
Winnipeg
we fully understand not everyone here in
Dolphin wants to talk to the media and
we have no interest in intruding in
their grief but some people do want to
tell us a little bit about their loved
ones Melissa region is with me Melissa
you've spent some time here yeah you
know Don there's a lot of grief that
still is hanging over this city there's
people who are trying to figure out who
is among those who are recovering who
has passed on when two families actually
have shared with us their loved ones the
loss that they've suffered uh Helen
cuffley and Shirley novakowski have been
confirmed we've talked with their
families
RCMP and health officials aren't
commenting any further this weekend we
can expect maybe some updates this week
though
and it's such a small community Melissa
what's it been like being here you know
the people have been so welcoming it's
um which is interesting sharing your
grief opening your your community to
strangers like the media who who come
here uh to report on things like this so
it's been incredible we've met some
fabulous people there's a Community
Support Center that's been open here
it's not well used I wouldn't say
there's not a big rush of people in
there lots of people are just grieving
at home we talked to the man who set it
up a counselor here and he said it's not
about the equal the quantity of people
who come through here it's what the quan
quality of care that they receive while
they're here
they might be a distant friend they
might be a neighbor that no one else
knew about and you wouldn't think to go
talk to them you know that to say do you
have a need
um but they came to us so that was that
was really good because they didn't know
where else to go and they felt they were
feeling really poorly there are a lot of
victims that no one sees
that really sums it up right exactly
that's who they're there for all right
Melissa Ridge and thank you oh thanks
for having me
all right many people in the community
of dolphin are turning to one another
trying to find some comfort and hope
whether it's through faith or a
fellowship while waiting for more word
on those who survived and those who are
never coming home Marnie blunt reports
Barry nadoli lights up the candles at St
Paul's Anglican Church the place of
worship looking to support those who are
struggling during dark days we're all in
the State of Shock and now we're into
into mourning and into grief and
disbelief
he says the community is Binding
Together in a time of need including all
the local churches and many have been
reaching out a few calls that say you
know I used to go to church but
um can I come on Sunday morning the
crash still a shock for a tight-knit
community Florence and Mike marchak say
they're waiting to hear the news and
names we haven't heard the names yet but
uh but we're we are sure that we would
know
the couple has lived in Dolphin for 90
plus years they say this is the most
devastating event to happen to their
Community it's too bad terrible for the
families and everyone a support center
is still set up at the recreation center
in Dolphin but the mayor says most are
staying with their loved ones during a
time of need I think there's a complete
range of emotions from being very
distraught or very involved and in this
because of a family or a very close
friend or relationship to other people
just feeling a collective sense of
sadness as being members of our
community some churches will be holding
special services Sunday morning
including the one here at St George's
Ukrainian Orthodox church to pray for
those who are still in hospital and to
honor those who tragically lost their
lives in this horrific crash Donna
all right Marty blunts thanks Marty
leaving families has been set up the
number to call is
204-647-5058 and a support center as
Marnie mentioned is also being run out
of the dolphin Lutheran Church for those
who feel they need it we'll be back from
Manitoba a little bit later but after
the break the rest of the day's news
including an horrific attack at a school
in Uganda pharah
some of the details are disturbing
dozens of teenagers are dead some
kidnapped after a rebel attack near the
border with Congo coming up the Manhunt
and who authorities believe is
responsible
plus no more fun in the sun as WestJet
details the future of sun wing Airlines
[Music]
a horrific scene unfolded in Western
Uganda late Friday night when suspected
members of an extremist group attacked a
local secondary school at least 41
people including students are reported
dead and some others have been abducted
and possibly taken into neighboring
Congo roughly two kilometers away as
ready zucchini reports this latest
attack is part of a string of assaults
launched by rebels and we want to warn
you tonight that some of you may find
these details very disturbing
standing behind a police line residents
of Empire
Uganda stared on at the horrors of an
attack on a secondary school dormitory
now in smoldering remains more than
three dozen people died many of the
victims bodies were found burned or
hacked
it's very unfortunate that a mistake was
made and our children have been killed
says this guard with the Uganda people's
Defense Forces
54 people were believed to have been at
the school with officials unclear how
many managed to escape there could be
others who ran into their homes and are
not yet here so the exact number is not
yet local authorities said in a
statement at least six students were
abducted and brought towards the massive
virunga National Park that spans some 7
700 square kilometers
that came to kill our people is it
security within Uganda the suspected
group behind the attack is the Allied
Democratic forces a group formed by
Ugandan Muslims in the early 1990s
opposed to the rule of the Ugandan
president I
will both the Ugandan and Congolese
governments have been working to root
out the terrorist organization which has
pledged allegiance to the so-called
Islamic State military strikes have
weakened it but its Guerrilla tactics
often strike a deadly blow
the military in this video from a local
newspaper says it believes the group
spent two nights near the school before
it was raided this is the deadliest
attack by the ADF since a suicide
bombing in 2021 in the capital of
Kampala the government is now using DNA
to identify the remains of the Dead in
this latest attack regi chikini Global
News
Russian President Vladimir Putin
interrupted remarks by visiting African
leaders seeking to mediate in the war
with Ukraine to say their proposals are
misguided
peace
Putin held up documents claiming the
African groups proposed peace deal with
Ukraine was actually initiated by Kiev
the leaders were welcomed in Kiev on
Friday where Ukrainian president
vlodimir zielinski told them he failed
to see what could be gained from the
group talking to Putin the war has
severely restricted the export of grain
to Africa intensifying food insecurity
in the region
WestJet is planning to shut down Sunwing
Airlines just weeks after it's finalized
its takeover of the company an internal
memo says sun wing will be integrated
under the main WestJet Banner within two
years adding the change will unlock
growth opportunities for both sun wing
and its employees there is no indication
sun wing vacations will also shut down
suggesting westjet's planes could be
flying sun wing tour package customers
to their destinations the change comes a
week after WestJet announced it would
also be folding its Ultra low-cost
carrier swoop
[Music]
one Community understands firsthand what
it's like to deal with an unexpected and
unimaginable tragedy ahead we speak with
the former mayor of Humboldt
Saskatchewan
there is one politician in this country
who probably understands better than
most the journey that the leaders and
residents of dolphin Manitoba will go
through in the coming days and weeks
five years ago then Mayor Rob Minch LED
Humboldt Saskatchewan through one of
Canada's most high-profile Highway
tragedies the fatal bus crash involving
the humble Broncos junior hockey team
Rob Minch joins us now he is a city
councilor at the moment but again was
the mayor at that time thank you so much
for being with us especially as I'm sure
this incident has been re-traumatizing
for for many uh in your community I know
you've spoken to the mayor of dolphin
what was that conversation like
well first and foremost uh I uh offered
my condolences uh to uh rare and to the
community of dolphin it's one of those
things where um
that's what you just go to right off the
bat it's just one of those things so
um we talked about a number of things
when we talked and uh I I offered him
any help that I could give uh in the
coming weeks and months to uh you know
if there's anything that we've learned
over the over the last few years that we
would be able to share
you and the leaders in your community
have such a unique perspective when you
look back five years later knowing what
you know now about this unimaginable
Journey what advice and lessons can
leaders in Dolphin learn from from your
experience
well we often talk about physical
injuries and that type of thing but
um I think we need to pay attention to
uh the trauma that's uh happened and and
uh The Grieving and uh the injuries uh
like the mental illness that uh can
happen in these types of situations so
make sure uh you know God is attended to
I mean this uh this crash has also once
again brought Road Safety into the focus
um do you think that there are gaps or
shortcomings on Rural roadways like this
one and has anything changed since the
Humboldt crash on Saskatchewan roads
well I think a lot of a lot of good has
come out of uh the accident in in
Humboldt uh five years ago
um these are all usually provincial
jurisdictions and I know the
Saskatchewan government has uh has been
working to uh increase safety in in a
lot of the intersections and that type
of thing so
um we often look at uh you know what
good can come out of a horrible tragedy
and and sometimes these things are uh
um these things are you know something
that we can look uh look as uh being
good coming out of a horrible situation
yeah you've spoken about that previously
I know how you've been you know relying
on looking at the positive uh to to help
you get through in terms of healing and
you know the entire country is watching
this tragedy so many people want to help
they're sitting at home they're
wondering what they should do what was
most helpful for your community at that
time
well just uh I guess uh the well wishes
and the the notes and the cards and that
type of thing um you know when you're at
uh when you're at the lowest you can be
sometimes uh just having having uh
people reach out and uh and uh tell you
that they're thinking about you and and
uh offering your prayers and uh well
wishes
um those go a long way to uh help uh
help in the healing process
um often people I think uh do these
gestures not only to help the receiving
end but to um for their own healing as
well
Rob Minch former mayor and now City
councilor of Humboldt Saskatchewan
thanks so much for your valuable Insight
in this difficult time
well thank you for having me
[Music]
next trucker is unpacking the Manitoba
tragedy we're back in dolphin with Donna
with what it's like to go through that
very intersection
and why some drivers were waiting for
this to happen
[Music]
there are thousands of truckers on
Canada's highways every day and you can
be sure all of them know about what
happened near Carberry Manitoba I was at
the Manitoba professional truck driving
championships earlier today and I spoke
with a man who trains long-haul truck
drivers and has driven that route on the
trans-canada highway himself multiple
times
I actually was unfortunate enough that
there was some pictures that were posted
on Facebook initially and then they were
taken down
um I seen one of them and it's something
you can't unsee what are drivers telling
you about that a lot of guys are saying
that we've been waiting for this to
happen in Manitoba for years Humboldt
was I remember being in the hockey or in
converting when we heard what happened
and it was like
we knew this was coming when you're
training them now when when students are
seeing what happened there is it it must
send a bit of a chill right well a lot
of them look at it and they're like what
happened so you try to explain to them
guys these are one of those things where
even though
we don't want to lay blame
but
even as a driver
of that boss did what he did
even you still as a commercial like when
you're driving truck it's more than just
sitting there listening to the radio
driving down the highway those
intersections are one of I teach the
students when we're in now I teach at
the city of Brandon so you're wanting
them to look two and three blocks ahead
all the time recognize what you're
seeing for what it is so when you're
coming now chances are that poor guy
with Dan Ross probably didn't have a
chance to react I drove into Winnipeg
last night from Brandon
the marks are all still there yeah you
can see exactly where the impact was
um when when truckers are driving past
that through any past any intersection
what goes
you see a vehicle pull up the first
thing in in my stomach and in my brain
is please don't move
and your foot and you're just waiting
and if you see them start to move at all
okay now you're into it like now it's
it's breaking time and some of them will
just shoot across in front of you some
people will move and then oh they seen
you and you see the vehicle jerk and
they stop okay good okay good we see and
you go by make eye contact with them
those two drivers of the bus and the
truck that's tough
well I'm thinking they're going to need
somebody to talk to for a while
um not only
of course
the fella that was driving that boss
um
that's gonna be awful
and then the truck driver where
what do you do you can see what's coming
and at a highway speed that is a hundred
kilometer an hour Zone through there
and even at 100K when you're pulling a
set like he was uh trailers if he was
fully loaded well I don't know what he
had on but
that happened all you can do is push
that brake pedal and Hope and
there is no hope there's no hope there
it's it's just everything happens so
fast
I I again I um you know
prayers and condolences to families
um I hope the drivers eventually can get
their feet sat on the ground and look
forward again
um we don't want to lay blade
we know what happened there's no point
in finger pointing it's not going to do
anybody any good at this point
condolences to the families of all those
involved that is global national for
this Saturday I'm Donna Friesen in
Dolphin Manitoba have a lovely evening
and thanks for watching bye-bye
thank you